a city in the sky nearly half a
kilometer saw the Boers debye is the
pinnacle of skyscraper edge
it owes its success to seven key
inventions we have lined up seven
landmark buildings historic Giants of
the skyscraper world at the heart of
each one lies a major technological
innovation and allowed engineers to
reach ever taller into the sky one by
one traveling up the scale will reveal
incredible stories behind these
structures and the inventions of seven
ingenious leads forward that have
enabled spaceman to have fun big to
bigger into the world's biggest
the first big obstacle to skyscrapers is
the stair people weren't willing to walk
lots of flights of stairs stairs and old
office buildings were wrong they were
very dark and people weren't ready to
climb stairs more than to the second
floor the third floor there's an obvious
solution to the problem the elevator but
then a mechanic from Vermont invents a
device that can stop a falling elevator
almost instantly it's a simple yet very
clever invention the critical element
the elevator rope is secured with a
powerful wagon spring mounted on top of
the cab this spring connects to a set of
metal prongs on each side of the
elevator the prongs run along guide
rails fitted with the road for TV when
the rope breaks it triggers a chain of
events the spring relaxes and forces the
metal prongs into the teeth locking the
cab enhance the elevator completely
transforms the urban landscape
this corner was the site of the
equitable Life Assurance company's
headquarters a building of extraordinary
significance because it was the first
office building with an elevator and
without an elevator the skyscraper would
be impossible the borscht turbine takes
the idea of the elevator to the extreme
equitable life at seven and a half
stories the Bois de Bie has over 160 a
height that stretches elevator
technology to its absolute limit